when you get out to LA how do you even
function like did you know like how do
you get an apartment how do you what do
you do I had a couple friends from from
school that were out here doing various
jobs and gigs and what have you kind of
surviving the one person that I knew
that had a had a Hollywood career was
Paul Rudd who I knew from back in the
Midwest and you know Paul had long
Michael Hutchence hair he had the cool
Duran Duran jacket like I it was like he
was everything that you thought the cool
guy from college looks like in 1988 and
he had he had just done clueless and
he'd just done I think he was going to
go do Romeo and Juliet so like he was on
his way we knew and he was nice to you
in other words he hadn't adopted a star
attitude like absolutely yeah absolutely
totally like well oh man it's great
you're coming out that's awesome
and I remember saying to him just like
look dude I'm not gonna like blow up
your spot you know all I need is one
phone number just give me one phone
number of somebody that I can call
that can be helpful
in some way and he did he gave me the
guy who was his first manager he said
call him he knows everybody and I sat in
a room with this dude for like three
hours the guy just talked and talked and
talked and I was like I guess this is a
good meeting I don't know this is this
is like a whole thing but I ended up
getting an agent out of that and then uh
and then I ended up going on
a million auditions and not getting any
of them what a generous guy you know I
don't know if I like if you showed up at
my door and you're like hey just give me
the name someone help me out here and
I'm like hey [ __ ] this guy he's a good
looking dude I don't need it he's gonna
be he's gonna I don't need him doing
well competition yeah I don't know you
know Paul Paul's always been that way
and is
um throughout my career in life has been
you know we've been friends for Going on
30 years now he told a great story I
guess you've heard it a million times
but he was a DJ Joe Buck who's also a
very good friend of ours Joe Buck and I
went to one of Paul's gigs in the
whatever early 90s to pick him up
because we were all going to go out and
haven't have a night and so there's some
13 well now whatever 47 year old woman
who most likely still lives on the west
side of Los Angeles who had at her Bar
Mitzvah Paul Rudd Joe Buck and Jon Hamm
ER and was uh blissfully unaware of all
of it and it was yeah I mean that's that
was his and we were jealous of him
having that job that was a good paying
gig what was his then he had a character
Donnie the dweeb who do this dance
called the Dork dance that that became a
as you as you must most likely know with
like uh that that circuit is fairly
small so then right if you have any kind
of of juice on that thing it becomes
like well you got to do the Dork dance
and then it's a I think he ended up
charging more for it I mean it was like
you know if you want the dance then it's
gonna be another you know 50 bucks